what do you think
about communism why doesn't it work
what uh
is it the implementation is there
anything about its ideas that you find
compelling
or is it just a fundamentally flawed
system well communism is like capitalism
the words mean
many things to different people yes you
could argue my life as a tenured
professor comes closer to communism
anything
the human race has seen and i would
argue it works pretty well
yeah but look if you mean the soviet
union
it devolved pretty quickly to a kind of
decentralized set of incentives that
were destructive
rather than value maximizing it wasn't
even central planning
much less communism so paul craig
roberts and paul any were correct in
their descriptions of the soviet system
think of it as weird mixes of barter and
malfunctioning incentives
and being very good at a whole bunch of
things but in terms of progress
innovation and consumer goods it really
being quite a failure
and now i wouldn't call that communism
but that's what i think of the system
the soviets had and it required an
ever increasing pile of lies that both
alienated people but created an elite
that by the end of the thing
no longer believed in the system itself
or even thought they were doing better
by being crooks
then by just say moving to switzerland
and being an upper middle-class
individual like you would have a
higher standard of living by gorbachev's
time not gorbachev but if you're number
30 in the hierarchy
you're better off as a middle-class
person in switzerland and that
of course did not prove sustainable and
so it's uh what is it a momentum a
bureaucracy or something like that it
just builds up or you lose control of
the
the original vision and that naturally
happens it's just people and you can't
use normal profit and loss and price
incentives so you get all prices
or most prices set too low right
shortages everywhere
people trade favors you have this
culture of bartered bribes
sexual favors or you know family friends
and
you get more and more of that and you
over time lose more and more of the
information and the prices
and quantities and practices and norms
you had
and that sort of slowly decays and then
by the end no one is believing in it
that would be my take but again you're
you're the expert here
the the russian scholar
well perhaps no more an expert than iron
rand
uh it's more personal than it is
scholarly
uh or historic
you